ragazzi al museo e della della scienza
di milano e sto giocando il guar perché
c'è il wire the martian lo sto
registrando perché io posso quindi ciao
io sto proprio approcciando il pianeta
come potremmo a ecco se un tizio
incastrato dal tipo ci sta svegliando il
cavo frate
come quanti svegli lunedì mattina e non
capisci dove sei quelli di andare a
scuola da lavoro a io sono il tizio
aspettano questa roba aspettano ferma
con questo dovrebbe essere il mio corpo
a quella il mio corpo io mi vedo fuori e
propone un'esperienza extracorporea
piripì quindi io vedevo il mio corpo
finissima e belli che abbiamo come
perché c'è ma il demon ci mettiamo un
aspetto aspetta che ci mettiamo era un
canale non ahimé diamo un sito che
qualche pecca regista missione diario di
watney ordinare le patate razionare le
patate pulire le patate io in queste
cose sono bravissimo poi abbracciare
teddy quello non lo so fare
rompere i piatti i cd di disco music
quello lo fa sasha e poi non ha finito
di leggere questo il mio culetto perché
dovrei riuscire a ricalibrare minato
perché vi vedo da fuori o adesso sono io
perfetto allora devo fare delle cose
tipo tipo il post che c'è una patata
ok perfetto aspetta non credo si faccia
quello però vabbè piano no ragazzi ci
sono dei problemi come cos'è dammi fuoco
e piazze andiamo fuoco alle patate ma so
che sta facendo più tipici ed è quello
che devo abbracciare come lo prendo uno
prendo te dici sedici prodotti
porro teddy questa è una gara fatta la
piccola quindi va nelle patate piccole
questa è un'altra patata piccola
quest'anno a catania
questa grossa però patate grandi fatto
che cosa ciò al braccio eh no dai
ragazzi su marte sopravvivere ai 5
minuti
queste piccole quelle piccole e le ho
messe tutte sono lebron james per quelle
grosse noi non questo bene grazie
sono sopravvissuto grazie demos per i
giorni sono un sacco di patate e ben
cinque ragazzi non ho capito che dovrei
fare per sopravvivere su marte non sono
capace manca sopravvive anche in casa
mia e affermato la pura
vedi che non sa vivere sofia faccio solo
casini se cucino regalo con il cavalca
sei scemo sembra di essere limonata dame
de mon
se devo fare qua fermi che ci sono le
cose radioattive prodotti vivere in
testa guarda o c'è qualcosa come ronaldo
si sta roba
c'è vita qui essere fai finta che sia
juve napoli il quale fisica non utilizza
nostra martellando la roccia bene via
scelta
ecco questo questa è una scatola di
piselli zio che ti fa paura
mamma mia con questo scuri che mi piace
nasa sono pronti di dare qua dentro
immagino si questo è il portafoglio e
poi basta
ma no finito questo fa devo mettere il
fagiolo dentro il contenitore va bene a
modificare questo am e damon più vecchio
è però sempre figo ma già teo perché mi
danno da fare delle cose che non so fare
poi faticoso la vita da marzia non
potevo fare l'ho youtuber basta secondo
te o soffrono di osteoporosi
io sono dentro roberts e non stiamo
facendo il giro robert tu non vedi lo
schermo ma ti giuro che sto facendo cose
simpatiche tipo andare incontro al è
tutta una questione di polso qua devo
evitare le rocce wow
poi ci sono dei tasti che non sa bene
cosa sono ma tiriamo di perché fa figo
guardali sì sì sì sì va bene tutto va
bene tutto basta che non mi espelle
dall'irvv al finestrino cara mamma mia
che guida mar ho parcheggiato meglio di
te stamattina zio correlati no no no
asca la badante che devo dare molto
lenta
no no no to write
533 giorni che sono vivo qua dentro
pensate come sta messo fra e buio pace
dalla corrente
premo il pulsante verde per iniettare
gli sportelli non c'è più salterebbe
sono daltonici questo è gettare ei e
allontanati perché cos'è l'ici come
posso allontanarmi di cosine che posso
fargli capire che non è che in campo da
calcio questione non so se hai visto
dove sono allontanati tories e 36
strizza l'ultima schiacciare i tasti a
caso dio perché sembra martin garics
vedi baby cui è stato qualcosa poi è
stato matt damon povero meglio
roub
siam partiti sono proprio bravo io sto
sto decollando sto tornando nello spazio
sto tornando a casa e anche togliamo di
non aver preso la multa macellari
aqsystem art
prendo io ho visto più niente st parte
lanciare oggetti a caso perché fai
vedere che la gravità e film iron man
mano a proseguiamo charme i dalla tuta
3000 chiusura della cintura da me tu
così da te lo devo fare
chiusura della cintura non si io sto
andando nello spazio ai gettato tutto
sta iniettando tutto quanto ho preso
perché esco spostando quel collari ha
capito come fa in gravity io muoia grace
spider man
vola vola vola che un casino
ora non so bene la fisica ma non credo
che facendo quesito spazio tu vada
effettivamente bisogno perché io vorrei
andare lì tipo a sto andando lì paroli
superman
super matt damon ha capito io visto
direzionando con la tuta al buco natura
mt sono ricordati
premettendo che
prende parte che stiamo andando nella
direzione giusta pur non sapendo fighter
è tutta di essere super nella realtà
franco ne ho avuta
storto con la morte non ci arriverò mai
sei scemo o a milano salvato zio questa
è la nostra nave di salvataggio di
dallamano
no non può lambrate sono adesso livello
mi sembra troppo realistico ai caffè che
con questi abbracciarli ma non lo fare
no non lo fare e non l'ho fatto io
rovinerei matt damon per il film di the
cage rega quando andati gli altri siete
scemi ma sto parlando da solo come un
idiota da un ora che non c'è nessun
stati via tutti a dove ero lì a giocare
col v harman lasciato da solo
[Musica]
maledizione di spaventato tutti si è
spaventato pensavo che arrivasse il menu
bellino e perché ripiega dopo
[Musica]